Six things that I would do if I were twenty two again.
In twenty minutes.
Number one
If I were 22 again, I would marry.
A radical risk-taking go anywhere for Jesus, world Christian woman.
in fact i would marry noel henry.
Not long after we met when I was 20.
I was head over heels in love, already talking about marriage, three weeks into this relationship, and said,
If God called me to be a missionary to Africa, would you go?
She said yes.
I would see myself called to be by your side wherever.
We married when I was 22, and my first job was teaching in
college,
and when i was thirty-three i felt the irresistible.
Call to be a pastor
And I asked her the morning after that,
meeting with God if she would support me in that and she said yes. One year into that ministry I was so discouraged I put my face in my hands at the dining room table
room table, she was in the bedroom, and I said out loud, pretty serious,
i think i'm going to africa.
and she didn't miss a beat from the other room and said
Tell me when to pack.
It's really stinky
This is really significant.
that
You marry the right.
Woman.
Four years into that ministry, we weathered that discouragement.
i said to her one day when god had met us in world missions powerfully at the church, i said what if we invited everybody from the church who was interested in missions to come over on friday night.
night.
And we'll just put them on the living room and dining room and see if we can inspire them.
And she said, "Sure, let's do that."
And 100 people showed up.
And and uh
Twice a year for twenty years, we had a hundred people in our living room down room and took all the furniture and put it upstairs in the bedroom.
That's a lot of work.
And, uh,
Women don't like their houses intruded upon like that usually.
So, lesson for you.
Um, yeah.
Pray
Unless you're called a signalist, pray that your future or present
Spouse,
be a radical risk-taking go anywhere for jesus world christian that's number one number two.
if i were twenty-two again i would.
Take that young life.
of mine and join a bible believing bible preaching bible structured bible obedient church
and I would take her to church every Sunday morning without
Fail.
And we would throw ourselves into the ministry of that local church in the hope that that community of believers would
Care for us and guard us and help us discover our gifts at age twenty two, three, four.
and then catapult us into a lifetime of ministry so we join lake avenue congregational church and
I passed it to you in California when we were 19 years old.
When I was 22, she was 23.
21.
and she discovered a gift for working with mentally disabled adults and i discovered a gift teaching by teaching seventh grade boys the first year in ninth grade boys.
Great Boys the second year. And the Young Galilean Marriage Sunday School Class, the third year of 2019.
And that deacon group
Took hold on me, and Glenn Dawson laid hold of me and watched over me for three years, sent me to Germany for three years, watched me at Bethlehem for a year, brought me out and they had
And they ordained me seven years later. That's a relationship you cannot take.
Overestimate.
So, lesson for you: Find a Bible-believing, Bible-preaching, Bible-structured, Bible-obedient church. Join it. Serve it. Discover your gifts there.
Be accountable to that community.
As they help you
Discover and follow God's call on your life.
number three
If I were 22 again, I would go to seminary.
and i would spend three or four years totally immersed.
in the most rigorous study of the greek and hebrew that i could possibly find if.
For a lifetime of fruitful,
discovery of the glories of Christ in the Word of God in such a way that I would never waver
No matter what, in my commitment to believe and speak whatever the Bible teaches,
Wherever God puts me.
I would not prioritize in seminary practical courses in northern
What we've been talking about,
as valuable as those are but every chance i got i would prioritize taking exegetical courses.
Because of my conviction at age 72 and
I would put it back on that 22 year old.
that in general practical skills are learned better on the job in the church
And, uh,
Deepening and sharpening of exegetical skills for a lifetime of fruitful reading our best
Accomplished.
In a rigorous give and take classroom setting with
The watchful eye of a skilled teacher.
Amen. Lesson for you, 1 Peter
Whether you attend seminary or not,
Become as Bible saturated as you can.
Putting yourself under the influence of the most insightful Bible teachers, both dead and alive.
number four.
If I were 22 again, I would resolve
To read my Bible every day for the rest of my life
As more important than eating
Or getting exercise, or kissing my wife.
There have been about 18,340 days since I turned 22.
And I think I have read my Bible on more of those days than I have eaten.
i have certainly read my bible on more of those days than i have watched television.
Or videos.
and i am also certain that i have read my bible on more of those days than i have kissed my wife because
she doesn't go with me on the road
usually like here and my bible does always does never leave my bible leave my wife not my bible.
But I have learned a few things.
about
reading the Bible that I didn't know when I was 22 and I would form my resolve at any two like at 22 like this
I resolve every day to read my Bible
And not to settle for a
A hazy, vague awareness of it.
but push through the haze to the wording itself and i would push into and through the wording of the text itself to the
to the intention of the authors, human and divine. And I would push through the intention to the reality behind the work.
the words and the grammar and the logic. And I would push into that reality until it was an emotionally experienced reality. And I'd push
pushed into and through that emotionally proportional reality until it became a word and a deed on my life. And I would push through that.
that deed and that word until other people saw the reality and joined me in my encounter with God in the Bible.
That's why i would formulate my resolution to read the bible every day
Nothing is revealed more quickly on the mission field.
Than a superficial
encounter with the Living God
and the glorious realities he has revealed in scripture, superficial bible reading that does not penetrate through the words and intentions and reality.
And reality and experience to deed and life and an encounter with the living God will be of little use on the mission field.
In the face of massive demonic forces.
Among the unreached peoples, you won't survive.
A lesson for you, read your Bible every day.
Every day of your life, no exceptions.
Never say
I'll read it
If I have time,
If you have time for breakfast.
If you have time for breakfast, you have time for your Bible.
skip
breakfast
Don't get your Bible reading pleasure
From the fact
that your conscience is clear because you checked the Bible box.
get your pleasure from reading the bible because of an encounter a meeting a fellowship with the living supernatural reality that you meet.
In the scriptures.
Number five.
If I were 22 again, I would become a Christian hedonist.
Which I did and would do again.
That is.
I would seek to find more joy in God than anything else in the world.
for the sake of personal holiness, perseverance through pain and promotion of the glory of God. That's why I would become a Christian hedonist. That is, I would get
would get clarity and certainty around the sentence, God is most glorified in you when you are most satisfied in him. I would nail that sentence and I would
and i would either believe it or not believe it and if i believed it i would go for broke and being as satisfied in god as i could possibly be 24/7
Seven, over everything.
else
Which means that
by means of savoring the sweetness of the promises of God in this precious book, I would put to death
every rising quiver of pride and self-reliance and lust and greed and fear and by the power of the Holy Spirit,
100% seek to kill all those sins by the superior pleasure that we have.
In
God.
Because unless those sins die,
I will be dogged from 22 to 72 by fruitlessness of life and damned in the next.
I would recognize at age 22 that the fight for joy in God
Through the bright,
100% in dismal circumstances of life, 100% in
Is the essential key
In my mission
in life for authenticating holiness, fruitful perseverance,
so that God gets the glory.
Being happy in God more than you are happy
in anything else is the key.
To holiness and fruitfulness.
to the glory of God. So, lesson for you.
become a Christian hedonist.
When you call it that or not, it doesn't matter.
Don't aim at the pleasures of fame. Don't aim at the pleasures of sexual gratification. Don't aim at the pleasures of wealth. Don't aim at the pleasures of fame.
Aim at the pleasure and contentment and comfort of safety. Aim at all satisfying joy. Joy.
In God.
Which will empower you
For humility and chastity and simplicity and risk-taking sacrificial love.
For other people.
Lastly, number six.
If I were 22 again, I would recognize that I am not my own.
that I have been bought with a price.
and that I belong, body and soul.
To Jesus Christ
For his use
In his glory in this world,
Any way he please.
And I would offer myself up to God at age 22 and tell Him.
Helps to say it out loud to him
Repeatedly.
Tell him!
That he may do with me.
Anything he pleases.
He may kill me. He may torture me.
He may send me anywhere.
He can do me no wrong. He owes me nothing.
And I would tell him that
Anytime he please, anywhere he please.
I am.
His.
At his disposal.
And I would memorize Psalm 25.
He's had a very crucial role for me.
In seminary.
I would memorize Psalm 25
And trust the amazing promises of guidance.
that are in those precious verses. Good and upright is the Lord.
Therefore,
He instructs sinners
In the way.
He leads the humble in what is right and teaches the humble.
His way.
You don't have to be left to your own wisdom as to what you spend your life doing if you believe those verses in Psalm 25. He's going to teach you to
You his
Way for you.
Lesson for you.
memorize psalm 25.
Pray it as your own.
And give yourself wholly up
to God and His.
Mission.
And trust him.
we do a lot more things at age 22 but that's what I would do
If I had 20 minutes to tell you.